welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse in venom 2 as an official title
venom - let there be carnage with its
release date delayed for October 20 22
June 20 21 not much of a surprise no
movie has been spared from these delays
but we are still here breaking it all
down because we might now have an idea
of what let there be carnage could mean
for the movie's plot I'm gonna explain
everything you need to know about
carnage and its venom sequel boiler
warning in case any my predictions into
being right in your life gets more
ruined than it already is not to get to
college philosophy for you but life is
what happens when your expectations get
spoiled okay so a reminder that we last
saw carnage Cletus Kasady in the post
credits scene of venom the serial killer
was being interviewed by Eddie Brock in
San Quentin prison outside San Francisco
making blood finger paintings waxing
poetic about the Dadaist patterns of
arterial spray and promising that when
he escapes you shouldn't beat carnage
carnage was introduced by Marvel Comics
as a somehow more extreme offshoot of
venom venom is a symbiote attached to
Eddie Brock Brock being an envious rival
to Peter Parker at the Daily Bugle and
the symbiote detaches our Peter Parker
and then it drips down onto Eddie
carnage is born when Eddie's symbiote
produces an offspring that attaches to
his prison cellmate Cletus Kasady
who's already a sadistic serial killer
so amplified that madman with venom ty
powers all this turned Marvel comics in
the 90s into a very gruesome place with
lots of disgusting body horror no the
Sony Universe has taken a slightly
different route with venom
there's no Peter Parker in this line of
succession Eddie Brock just gets
infected with the symbiote while
investigating human testing by the light
foundation so while venom in the comics
is a monstrous reflection of spider-man
with a spider-man inspired logo and inky
tendrils inspired by Peters
web-slinger's the movie venom has no
logo it is a sling and swing around the
city like spider-man so much as like
rides motorcycles
swims real fast jumps and like sloshes
watch spider-man who's lost now we have
seen some leaked set photos and videos
Woody Harrelson as Cletus Kasady on the
streets of SF with Cletus is short red
hair and skull necklace Hawaiian shirt
but we have been left to wonder what his
blood colored symbiote form will look
like there was also some rumored VFX
test footage that went around most of us
doubt its authenticity but now what they
confirmed a title like let there
be carnage we can turn to the pages the
comics to help us visualize what kind of
horrifying plot this movie could have
two of the most popular carnage centric
events in the Marvel Comics both have a
high body count and leave us with some
scarring imagery the first is maximum
carnage one of the earlier carnage
titles from 1993 later adapted into a
Sega game and a 2002 experience at
universals Halloween Horror Nights at
islands of adventure in Orlando that
scared the hell out of eighth-grade Eric
already traumatized from the event
horizon for years earlier now set on the
path to never return to the state of
Florida if I can help it maximum carnage
features Cletus Kasady breaking out of
the Raven crop Institute and teaming up
with shriek no shriek trick is love
shrek is life to form a kind of family
which ends up including the spider-man
doppelganger shriek uses her empathic
powers to cause new yorkers to erupt
into violence and rioting kind of like
mentally announcing let there to be
carnage to all of manhattan there are
crucifixions in Times Square torture
sessions in the Statue of Liberty
çb closes there's lines at Duane Reade
oh wait that's real life it takes an
alliance of Eddie Brock venom spider-man
black cat Morbius iron fists other
ground level New York Marvel characters
since the Avengers in Fantastic Four
can't be bothered apparently to stop
this carnage family if let there be
carnage goes in this direction perhaps
Eddie Brock could get some help from dr.
Michael Morbius despite the popularity
of maximum carnage it is a New York
story and it seems like this venom
sequel will be set in San Francisco and
there is a more recent carnage of it in
the Marvel Comics I think director Andy
Serkis might be pulling from because if
you think about it let there be carnage
is specific phrasing with biblical
overtones like it's booking gods first
words in a book of Genesis like you can
imagine in cletus kasady taking refuge
in an abandoned church scariest two
places they each in a kind of black mass
preaching from the altar doing is weird
woody dance carnage and for that
nightmare we have to turn to the Church
of carnage explored an absolute carnage
yes this concept does sound a bit
frightening but you know what these days
it is quite relieving to distract
oneself with fictional horror content
well thanks to shudder for sponsoring
this video
AMC shudder is the Netflix of horror
shudder is declaring April as halfway to
Halloween month and is launching their
biggest month of non October programming
ever they even have a Halloween
a line where you can call up and get
personalized movie recommendations from
shudders curator actually I just watched
escape from New York on shutter and I
loved everything John Carpenter does and
these days escape from New York is like
ively prophetic since those of us living
in big cities want nothing more than to
escape these health escapes tons of
great thrillers horror and supernatural
movies and TV shows with no ads for just
$5.99 a month works on your Smart TV
Xbox one your phone or any other way you
might watch new rock stars they've got a
ton of great original content like
creeks show TV produced by Greg Nicotero
from The Walking Dead and the last
drive-in with Joe Bob Briggs get started
streaming with the best horror thriller
and supernatural content Joe ders
expertly curated collection includes
titles like Texas Chainsaw Massacre old
boy and Halloween to try shut it for
free for 30 days go to shudder calm and
use the promo code rockstars
that's si tu D de are calm and use the
promo code rockstars for 30 day three
okay so absolute carnage is an insane
crossover event and more recent years to
the Marvel Comics it explores the
backstory and mythology of the symbiote
Clint our race and their deity know who
actually decapitated a celestial using
all black the Necker sword that led to
the Marvel setting of nowhere this
ancient null religion died out but an
absolute carnage carnage attempts to
resurrect the religion with him as it's
unholy leader at one point he spits out
these worm like pieces of itself to
infest homeless people in San Francisco
turning them into an army of drones
actually the set video of Woody
Harrelson shows that they're shooting in
San Francisco's Tenderloin district
which is known for a high concentration
of homeless people so yeah this really
dark plot line could be something they
explore in the film absolute carnage
ties in a ton of Marvel characters
including spider-man Miles Morales Eddie
Brock II and his son Dylan Brock
Deadpool scream iron fist others while I
don't think we would see this kind of
line up in an absolute carnage movie
what do you Harrelson's take on carnage
could absolutely be the same cult minded
psychopath that carnage is in the comics
it's almost like the let there be
carnage title is a response to cletus's
promise at the end of venom there's
gonna be carnage and then the response
from of course
let there be carnage carnage and a
sequel could be a Charles Manson style
cult leader who invests his sadistic
worldview into a broad family of
murderers intent on destabilizing
society in San Francisco
turning
upside down like a purge scenario and
exploring this idea of people who might
want to invite this kind of symbiosis
prefer living in a hive mind network
let there be carnage could follow what
would have happened if the alien
shapeshifter and John Carpenter's The
Thing made it off of Antarctica and
arrived at a populated port like San
Francisco total global exposure was that
creatures mission after all and for all
we know from the things open-ended
finale it might have achieved its goal
in that universe
let there be carnage could show the very
terrifying implications of that kind of
alien infection carried out what do you
think the title let there be carnage
means for the venom to plotz comment
down below with your thoughts and you
may have seen that we have been doing
these watch longs for the Marvel
infinity saga films you can join those
on discord by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash new rockstars follow
me on instagram and twitter at EA vods
follow new rockstars and subscribe to
breakdowns of everything marble thanks
for watching bye
[Music]